[Music]  oh i'm looking forward to this all day  come on let's go  go where my new hiding place  hey hold on just over here  [Music]  oh my gosh what is this they're just  like us  they  the uprights could be out here somewhere  if you don't take a chance now  this is war for  he's attracted  hello are you upright we didn't think  there were any orphans left this is  amazing  it was because of men that our ancestors  fled or stayed behind and we changed no  hands look at this  you can take them off  it's just a trip oh  you distract me  look at me the distraction what are you  [Music]  [Music]  there's something noble inside of you  mostly something worth fighting for  [Music]  [Music]